francis president suffers a major
setback emmanuel macron's party loses
control of the national assembly and the
far left and far right make historic
gains in the legislative election so how
will he govern over the next five years
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm adrian
finnegan france's president is facing
five years of political turmoil
following unprecedented results from the
legislative election emmanuel macron's
centrist coalition has lost its majority
in the national assembly it's the first
time that's happened to a president's
party in 20 years the biggest winners
were the far right at the far left less
than half of eligible voters cast a
ballot in the second round on sunday the
national assembly speaker lost his seat
along with the ministers for health and
the environment so where did the seats
go well the national assembly chamber
has 570
members emmanuel macron needed 289 seats
to keep a majority and although the
president's centrist ensemble coalition
remains the biggest party it secured
only 245 seats
a left-wing alliance the new ecological
and social popular union dubbed noop
united behind the left leader jean-luc
melecho
it's said to be the main opposition
group with 131 seats and the biggest
surprise the far-right leader marine le
pen's national rally party scored 89
seats up from just eight
five years ago
the traditional right the republicans
saw their vote collapsed to 61 seats the
remaining 51 are held by other parties
well leaders of the far left and far
right say they're determined to
complicate macron's legislative agenda
it's a totally unexpected situation
absolutely unheard of the collapse of
the presidential party is total and no
majority is presented we have achieved
the political objectives that we had set
ourselves in less than a month to bring
down the one who with such arrogance had
twisted the arm of the whole country who
had been elected without knowing what
for
i think that everyone considers that
this is a victory for the
monastery we're entering the assembly
with a very powerful group of mps we're
the first opposition party ahead of la
france and sumits and consequently we're
going to be able to work as an
opposition group as i had requested from
the french people we will operate with
full power with all the means that are
granted by the constitution to an
opposition group which is the first one
in the assembly
we'll begin our discussion in just a
moment but first jonah hull reports from
paris
a dreadful election this for emanuel
macron and his centrists in parliament
who've lost a hundred of their seats and
their absolute majority they will now
have to find new alliances in parliament
either on a case-by-case basis or some
sort of formal hookup if they're to pass
any legislation at all and the
likelihood is they'll start talking
immediately to the traditional right the
republicans with whom they've worked
before they have 61 seats macron needs
44 seats to hit the majority line no
guarantee that that will be successful
and so there is at least the prospect of
deadlocked government over the next five
years with an economic crisis worsening
here in france that's not the only
problem they face the centrists
increasingly hemmed in now in parliament
between rising forces on the left and
the far left and the far right with
marine le pen's success the success of
her national rally party and there's an
additional question over participation a
majority of french voters didn't take
part in this election three-quarters of
young voters between 18 and 24 didn't
take part in this election they simply
don't have faith and trust in their
politicians to solve their problems and
so
the possibility is that rather like the
giles protests during macron's first
term that during his second again people
may choose to take their problems to the
streets i'm joe nahul for inside story
so let's bring in our guests from paris
we're joined by political analyst ahmed
kriet uh in london is uh philippe
moliere who is a professor of french and
european politics at university college
london and from santander fabrice
poitiers ceo of rasmussen global a
political consultancy gentleman welcome
to inside story let's start with you
then hamid um what do you make of these
election results um was this election
as some french newspapers have said a
political earthquake to what extent does
the makeup now of the national assembly
make france ungovernable for the next
five years
well as you said it is unver
ungovernable for the french president
the current french emanuel macron i
believe it's a huge victory for the
leftists and the others party which is
the far right marine le pen
they have lost more than 100 seats in
the french parliament so i believe it's
a victory for the leftists we've seen
that the majority couldn't you know go
underground to in order to persuade to
argument for the french election the
importance of this parliamentary
election
and we've seen it's a huge defeat for
the french president
there is also you know
a lot of doubt about the democracy do
not forget that we had the yellow vest
movement uh uh which
were very you know uh they had the anger
against these french prisoners which is
very impopular so i believe now the
abstention is which is the important
point that a lot of people you know
forget about it the the abstention is
more than 52
that people d you know did not vote
we've seen we are in the same scenario
that in
1988 with the
uh the former president francois
mitterrand that when he had to uh
consolidate his
majority in the parliament so he had to
compose with the communist party and the
centuries so we have in the same you
know scenario and this is will of course
change the political map in the french
parliament so i believe now there is a
huge doubt about the democracy but also
french people are fed up they do not
believe in the democracy and
i think the most challenge is to
convince them that democracy is very
important for our institution okay
philippe molyer uh in london professor
um to what extent then will the next
five years be about tortuous negotiation
political compromise for both the
president and his party will they be
able to find some consensus
and some parliamentary stability
yes indeed hello uh first of all
yes macron's party and macro himself
will have to learn to compromise
something he hasn't done much uh to date
uh because falling short of 43-44 seats
in parliament is a lot and he will need
absolutely to get those votes in
parliament whenever
his party
and government want to to pass
legislation not to be
legislation which might prove
controversial with
other parliamentary groups notably
with the left
and there's only one way for macron now
given that he's got a solid block to his
left with noops which has really largely
increased
his total share of the votes and seats
is to turn to the right and to turn to
the republicans
the party of former president sarkozy
and this party of course could really
core less and work alongside uh macron's
party on a number of issues not to be
economic policies however it's an
opposition party and i think the
president of the party
said it yesterday on french tv we are an
opposition party so in fact the stakes
are very high because you will have to
compromise but also
to give to make some concessions with
with the right and it remains to be seen
whether the right will want to enter in
a coalition even if it's a kind of
addock type of coalition not a formal
one
because of course being in a position
party
the republicans will think about what
comes next in five years time macron
will have to retire as president he
can't run again so of course this party
will sort of think twice whether to
commit itself to
a party and a president which are
increasingly unpopular
fabrice forte in in santander then what
concessions will uh email macron have to
make to ensure the support of of the
republicans in the assembly and and
will that mean that that his government
has to shift to the right
well i think on the last point of your
question that's not necessarily from
another problem for emmanuel macron who
has been governing mostly on the right
over the past five years uh i think the
main
kind of compromise he can make towards
the republican is in appointing
potentially a new prime minister who's
got either who is coming from that
family or has enough credibility with
the conservative right to be able to
reach out and work with them but i think
more globally
what this um election results tell us is
basically this has been brewing for for
a while now where you have to imagine
that a lot of french people french
voters felt that they had already voted
twice in the second round of
the last two presidential elections
foreign macon by default because
basically it was either macron or an
extremist
like marine le pen and and there was
this frustration that i think many
french voters felt they could finally
overcome in the uh legislative elections
yesterday by being able to vote for the
preferred candidate or the preferred
party and i think this is important that
that i think about the macon
this is not something new this is not a
kind of freak accident but actually it
reflects something that has been growing
in french politics for the past five
years or more just to finish this is the
the the result of uh the main
mainstream party is mostly the socialist
party and the republican shrinking or in
the case of the socialist kazi
disappearing and emmanuel macron kind of
seating
uh
omash movement into as the center ground
main party and and in front of that you
have now two very strong uh extremes and
this is obviously a rather unhealthy
landscape for democracy where you have
to choose between a center or two
extremes and i think the next five years
will tell us if he and his partners in
government will manage to rebuild
something that is more than just a
single center ground party but some
political proposition that is more
attractive to french voters so they
don't have necessary to go and vote for
either the extreme left or the extreme
right okay i want to pick up on what
you're saying that and put the same
question to to all three of you here if
you can give me
reasonably brief answers um
i want to know
whether you think or to what extent
president macron is the architect here
of his own problems uh we'll put that
one to to um hamid first
well of course he's the architect he
entered it because of him the uh you
know the far right enter it in the
french parliament for the first time he
was the country that who passed the
global bills he passed the uh the law or
the islamophobic law which is the
separatist he was the candidate that
wants to uh increase the you know the
age of retirement to 60 to 65. so they
all all these old measures are very in
popular and that's why we have these
consequences of you know of a clearly a
condemnation of his all reforms
okay philippe
yes a really agree with what your your
guest just said here i i think clearly
uh macron came and i think that's
probably
something really to bear in mind when he
was elected five years ago for the first
time he was before
a minister in a socialist-led government
so he came really to the presidency with
a kind of aura or profile if you like of
a young modernizer but which which could
somehow reconcile you know bits of the
left and bits of the right and that's
exactly how he so-called saw this
political project i'm neither left-wing
or nor right-wing i'm in a way both of
both of them let's take the best of of
of both worlds in a way
and it seems that now five years down
the line is lost is a so-called
left-wing you know ie people who also
came
with them
uh from the socialist party you know
former mps or simply voters who used to
vote for the center-left party the
socialist party until 2017 who were
quite appealed by his political project
or modern modernization but now it's
very clear that on economic issues but
also on law and order on cultural
societal issues it can't be labeled
center center left that that's all
though no one believes in that now is
clearly a man on the right some put it
very much to the right others think is a
kind of santa right it depends on your
how you you on on your take on that but
anyway no one takes him as a sort of
center life leader so that's why clearly
is now in a kind of trouble and can only
turn to the right to to carry on and to
try to to to seek a majority and fabrice
i mean to what extent is is this
macron's macron's own fault
i i think to to go into the question of
whether it's his fault it's not
necessarily the right way to put it i
will say that he has taken advantage of
what he saw maybe before uh many other
actors uh the the fall of the
traditional parties especially the
socialist party and that's why he was
elected uh mostly as on the center left
ticket was a center-left leader even
though he governed on the on on the
right and and he saw that maybe before
others and he took advantage and he got
elected to everybody's surprise so but i
think he was more an actor than the
creator of the collapse of this
center left center right partition front
however uh his responsibility is that
the previous speaker is right that he
has been using a lot of the
conservatives to to hard right agenda on
on national identity or law and order
which in a way has normalized the agenda
carried by the respondent national and
now they have
basically multiplied by 10 the numbers
of n p sitting in the assembly national
what does this election mean for
jean-luc melenchon at his block which is
which is now the the biggest opposition
force in france
well for of course it's a tremendous
victory for jolick melenchon the lefties
because he you know he realized a very
huge coalition with the you know the
popular the suburb area and the leftist
and the ecologists and others political
party so i believe now it's of course a
tremendous victory for jonathan minocho
and of course johnny martial will play a
major role in the uh this new coalition
which is called nips but i believe what
is the most important things is now the
republican front uh has been exposed
because of emmanuel macron uh he did not
give any instruction in order to vote
for the leftist against
against the far right and do not forget
that when we have the presidential
election uh
emmanuel were beginning
the leftists in order to to gain this
precision election and if today he is a
president is because of the leftist
voters that help him to win this
election and this is i believe it's a
very important point now we don't have
this republican front and it's a very
dangerous steps for this president who
normalized the far-right party in the
french parliament which is i believe it
will be very dangerous for the stability
of the french society and the the
political map in the french parliament
what philly what do you make of of the
success of the the national rally of
marine le pen in uh this election eight
to 89 seats
what does that tell us
well if you if you compare with the
the other guest just said that it was a
tremendous success for the united left
nupsa i would beg to differ a bit i
would i would say they've made uh
considerable gains but it's not
uh sort of tremendous success i think
you could argue now although she got far
less seats than you united left
let's bear in mind that united lives
there's at least four if not five
parties together so that's
uh put to put things in perspective so
in the end it's not maybe not such
massive gains
whereas for her you know she used to
have eight mps including yourself in the
previous parliament now she's got 89.
and that's really an achievement and
that's of course very worrying for all
those in french society and elsewhere
think that of course the far-right uh
may not in power may not be a good idea
for france for europe and the world in
general
yes and that what what it shows is it is
that the uh far right the national rally
keeps making gains
for a very long time one used the same
french politics french political
commentators used to say
there's a glass ceiling for the far
right you know they will be doing quite
well in the presidential election
because it's a nominal election personal
the le pen's father and daughter are
well known to the public so they will
get good scores however they will never
get elected well look last time around
she came even closer to power and macron
the margin between macron and herself
wasn't that big anymore the same applies
now with the other
election legislative election where the
party
until now couldn't make significant
gains in the two ballot major return
system now they're able to do so they're
able to win 89 so 89 constituencies and
not simply in the traditional bastions
of the south east and the north and
northeast but now in the pyrenees region
in akitan in dardon in central france
they get mps elected so that shows that
there's a nationalization of the
far-right vote it's a party which may
not be seen anymore by some french
voters as a threat to democracy as an
extreme party
and that's why i think everyone opposing
the the far-right international rally in
france
have a lot to worry about
fabrice given that that that glass
ceiling that philippe was talking about
appears to have been shattered here
can marine le pen's party
any longer be described as as an extreme
has the overton window shifted here is
it is it now mainstream
well i think that it's still extreme in
their views and the agenda that they
carry but clearly now they are building
roots into the political the french
political system and this is of course
to
uh worry uh especially in what will come
after macron's mandated in five years
time uh just as to add uh to the
previous point
i think indeed the uh left-wing
coalition led by men
looks like the the biggest winner on the
outside but on the inside this is a very
uh uh
fragmented group and and my prediction
is that they are going to have quite a
lot of challenge to stay together uh the
each party that makes that group will
try to obviously form their different
groups inside the uh french national
assembly and i think there are already
some some tensions between the communist
leader and
and i think you can bet on macron trying
to steer the french environmentalists
away from that coalition closer to the
center left so i think this is probably
going to be they're going to fight
more with each other or as much with
each other as with macomb the real
danger and i agree with the previous
speaker is really coming from uh marine
depending on national was the more
coherent force and we will clearly
prepare itself for the next presidential
election in five years time and philippe
i'm just going to come back to you i'll
be i'll be with you again in a moment
habit but but philly with several high
profiles in the president's
party voted out in this election the
president himself as you said unable to
run again at the end of this uh this
this term what is the future for
for on march or renaissance i mean does
it have a future without macron
well it's a it's a very important
question it's very hard to tell right
now what will be the future of homage
and particularly
the one certainty as you just uh pointed
out is that macron will not run again so
we'll probably retire from active
politics
in less than five years years time
you might argue enough time for a new
young leader to emerge and replace it
well there they are you know like the
former prime minister dua philippe which
who by the way doesn't belong to our
marsh it's another small party called
horizon
uh he might be he might step in so and
other people might step in but i think
it's for the time being
macro has a problem with uh la public
it's a bit of an empty shell and it that
election showed again that there are no
real activists uh on the ground uh there
there are no local barons
this is what you need for a party to be
successful and durable you know and be
exist have a long life and it doesn't
have that and clearly if you add to it
the fact that the three ministers lost
the election and mike warned before the
election any minister losing
uh the the battle in that constituency
will have to resign and leave the
government so that and the the speaker
of the house also lost his seat so he
will have to to go so
this is really a party where you don't
even have in this current uh legislature
you know heavyweights so all the the few
heavyweights he had he lost them
yesterday so that's a it's a very
difficult situation and yes for the time
being that the future of the public on
march looks quite uncertain and happy
we've spent the last 20 minutes or so
talking about an extraordinary election
but we have to remember uh ultimately
but this was on a voter turnout of of 46
how
or what does that tell us about how
french voters feel about french politics
why did did more than half of the
country's electorate stay away
well
very good question you asked me because
i think it's very important today there
is a lot of you know crisis in france uh
do not forget that we have the yellow
vest movement and the uh russian
invasion uh uh as a result we have the
uh inflation and people do not see you
know a change for themselves so they see
that they live in the same property
they've seen the inequality and they've
seen that there's not you know the race
of the salary the minimum wage of salary
that's why johnny can usually want to
increase the minimum salary to 60 to 100
300 to 105 1000 sorry 500 euro so i
believe people now are fed up they do
not believe in the democracy they
believe in you know protesting in the
spring
asking for social reform in order to
fight the inequality and the poverty
that's why today the old french
parliament in the reality did not
represent the entire french people and
this is i think is a very dangerous
steps for the stability of the regime
the fifth regime
fifth republic is
losing now his architecture in the our
institution okay sorry to cut you short
mohammed we are we're out of time
many thanks indeed for being with us uh
gentlemen hamid quiet uh professor
philip marlier and fabrice poitier
and thank you too for watching don't
forget you can see the program again at
any time by going to the website at
aljazeera.com for further discussion go
to our facebook page at facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story and you
can join the conversation on twitter our
handle at aj inside story from me adrian
finnegan and the whole team here in doha
thanks for watching i'll see you again
bye for now